what are the solutions to the system of
equations y is equal to x plus 1
and x squared plus y squared is equal to
25. so let's first just visualize what
we're trying to do so let me try to
roughly graph these two
these two equations so my y-axis
this is my x-axis
this right over here x squared plus y
squared is equal to 25 that's going to
be a circle centered at zero with radius
radius 5. you don't have to know that to
solve this problem but it helps to
visualize it so if this is 5
this is 5
5 5 this right over here is negative 5.
this right over here is negative 5. this
equation would be represented by this
set of points or this is a set of points
that satisfy this equation
so let me
there you go trying to draw it as close
to a perfect circle as i can
and then y equals x plus one y equals x
plus one is a line of slope one with a
one y-intercept so this is one two three
four y-intercept is there it has a slope
of one so it looks something
looks something like this so we're
looking for the solutions we're looking
for the points that satisfy both the
points that satisfy both are the points
that sit on both so it's that point let
me do it in green it's this point and
it's this point right over here so how
do we actually figure that out well the
easiest way is to well sometimes the
easiest way is to substitute one of
these constraints into the other
constraint and since they've already
solved for y here we can substitute y in
the blue equation with x plus 1 with
this constraint right over here so
instead of saying x squared plus y
squared equals 25 we can say x squared
plus and instead of writing a y we're
adding the constraint that y must be x
plus 1. so x squared plus
x plus 1
squared
squared must be equal to 25 and now we
can attempt to solve for x so we get x
squared plus now we square this we'll
get right in magenta we'll get x squared
plus 2x plus 1 and that must be equal to
25.
we have 2x squared now i'm just
combining these two terms 2x squared
plus 2x plus 1 is equal to 25.
now we could just use the quadratic
formula to
find the the well we have to be careful
we have to set this equal to 0 and then
use the quadratic formula so let's
subtract 25 from both sides and you
could get 2x squared plus 2x
minus 24 is equal to 0.
and actually let's just to simplify this
let's divide both sides by 2 and you get
x squared plus x
minus 12 is equal to 0. and actually we
don't even have to use the quadratic
formula we can factor this right over
here what are two numbers when we take
their product we get negative 12 and
when we add them we get positive 1.
well positive 4 and negative 3 would do
the trick
so we have x plus 4
times x minus 3
is equal to 0 so x could be equal to
well if this is if x plus 4 is 0 then
that would make this whole thing true so
x could be equal to negative 4 or
x could be equal to
positive 3. so this right over here is a
situation where x is negative four this
right over here is a situation where x
is three
so we're almost done we just have to
find the corresponding y's and for that
we can just resort to the simplest
equation right over here y is x plus one
so in this situation when x is negative
four
y is going to be that plus one so y is
going to be
negative three
y is going to be negative three this is
the point negative four comma negative
three
likewise when x is three
y is going to be equal to four so this
is the point three comma four these are
the two solutions to this non-linear
system of equations